das preis möchte ja wirklich absetzen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
folglich geht mir richtig geiles video
hat muss aber erstmal sagt ich bin nicht
alleine ich hab meine mit honig zusammen
und es ist ja kein ganz sicher auch
schon gelesen heute haben wir uns
gedacht ich komme es gibt sogar als ich
weiß nicht erkennt dass schon früher ich
hab mir gerne die fenster zu vergessen
die kennt jeder von euch habt an jeder
tankstelle an jedem 4
und die waren echt immer so wenn jemand
aber ich habe mich fragten wir feiern
bietet noch mehr da und war okay leute
und war haben wir hier nicht eine
packung toxic waste sagen es lief auer
kennt hast du das in verschiedene warten
und waren hiervon waren voll oder von
toxic way
die solvay ziemlich dabei die daten bei
materiell wir haben management und ich
habe auch england ich bin ja alle wisst
ihr und einfach nur diese baumart
probieren würden wir machen nämlich mehr
existent klar natürlich probieren wir es
macht aber dann schlägt nicht so dass du
nicht zu
doch einem bunten necker island
auch das möchten und auf youtube channel
der nominierung zeichen von den youtube
kanal können ja mal vorbei sondern gibt
auch noch mit meinen part dazu stehen
wir auch mal hier ein paar rolle wenn er
sowas feiert und wird vielleicht auch
mal ich hab mal nachgeschaut wie
schärfte sickenberg bak basel
dies gibt probieren und zu gucken auch
anders richtig gut essen kann lassen
doch augen da bin ich gespannt und
beratung zur seite
also ja es war meine taktik war und
jetzt warten wir auch noch mal jetzt
melden wolle wasser strömen zeigt uns
janko hält das anders ist er jetzt ein
negativer wert auch probieren
ok damit anfangen ich würd lange
probieren erst mal 14 von 1
und das machen wir die fünf auf einmal
challandes okay die exzellenz für üben
wir probieren
sicher das ist einfach gar nicht sauer
oder dunkel probieren
aber schmeckt aber nicht sauer
vielleicht probieren wir erzählen hier
die gelbe zitrone orange so übel aus
nicht okay kommt kann man darüber im
feld der komplette kauf wir können von
dem ich denke dafür
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt die ultimative toxic
waste um 13.45 und geht massa in ordnung
[Musik]
also leute wir haben ja beide zum stück
alter pflegeheim die sterne
wenn ich die auf etwa leute wenn ich die
5 auf es dann will ich auch im video
arbeitet vielleicht recht studieren
gefehlt wer schnell fährt wahrscheinlich
auch gegessen hat auch die der verlierer
bei schlappen machen wie schreck in die
kommentare
strafen machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die aufgabe
[Musik]
zeigen sie mir auch nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
gehabt
ein mächtiger
[Musik]
ich hab's geworden
ich habe gewonnen ich habe gewonnen
jetzt natürlich für den kollegen
bestrafen aufdecken was richtig viele
etwas richtig wissen dass berlin dann
erst verlor etwa verfüge aber ich hatte
noch nicht restlos ist im mund ohne ich
hab keinen 50 leiharbeiter schaut bei
ihr vorbei bei 12
wir warten mal keiner ab wenn ihr das
mit den schicken angehäuft und 1 judith
kennel werden jetzt die anderen getestet
makro kinokarten sind und kann gut sein
das ist auf jeden fall dabei nicht
vergessen von münster und wir sehen uns
morgen wieder beim ein video auf morgen
19 uhr und ist die jetzt gleich was ich
noch machen weil mein herz lunge und ich
merke nicht so ich mache ich mehr wenn
auch noch mehr
ich würde natürlich